Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:打完游戏抢红包贼开心
Jake: Playing games and grabbing red envelopes is so much fun.
Shure: 你在这打游戏来着是吗
Shure: You were playing games here, right?
Shure: 收下收下
Shure: Accept it, accept it.
Lucia: 哎我今天早上拿上来一包好像
Lucia: Hey, I think I brought up a pack this morning.
Jake:他这有貔貅吗
Jake: Does he have a pixiu?
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: What he has is...
Lucia: 哎没有吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't he?
Lucia: 那我再拿一把
Lucia: Then I'll take another one.
Jake:不是就是外外
Jake: No, it's just for outside.
Shure: kitanweps
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Jake:这里还有一些遗留溪秀
Jake: There are still some leftovers here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:凑一凑长一长
Jake: Gather it up and make it longer.
Shure: 那筷子
Shure: And chopsticks.
Shure: 能使吗
Shure:  Can we use them?
Shure: 还要使刷一下
Shure: Still need to give them a brush.
Tasha: 稍微冲一下吧
Tasha: Just rinse them a bit.
Alice:哪个呀
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这是
Alice: This one.
Shure: 最多赚了快1万
Shure: Made almost 10,000 at most.
Shure: 最后一分钱没赚
Shure: In the end, didn't make a cent.
Shure: 为什么因为这个问题太多了
Shure: Why? Because there were too many problems.
Shure: 因为扫幅太大了
Shure: Because the sweep was too wide.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们钱币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:我们货币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Shure: 我们的币
Shure: Our currency.
Shure: 子上链了家人们
Shure: It's on the chain, folks.
Jake:大家大家忘掉这件事情
Jake: Everyone, everyone, forget about this.
Jake:10年之后再想起来
Jake: Remember it in 10 years.
Shure: 然后就发现自己富了是吗
Shure: Then you'll find out you're rich, right?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:财务自由职业自由
Jake: Financial freedom, job freedom.
Shure: 真的会吗杨老板
Shure: Will it really happen, Jake?
Tasha: 往我的账户里面先充5050个
Tasha: First, top up 5050 in my account.
Jake:总共150个
Jake: A total of 150.
Shure: 什么时候能让我实现财富自由呢
Shure: When can I achieve financial freedom?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:那就得
Jake: That depends.
Alice:快的话今晚就可以
Alice: If it goes well, tonight.
Jake:你
Jake: You.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么做的这个哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, how is this done, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这已经开始画饼了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, starting to dream, huh?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Shure: 今天晚上你先选一个别的笔然后
Shure: Tonight, you pick another pen first.
Tasha: 12345少个櫈子
Tasha: 12345, missing a chair.
Tasha: 再来个凳子
Tasha: Get another chair.
Tasha: 哦 还少一个凳子
Tasha: Oh, still missing a chair.
Jake:好吃吗火烧
Jake: Is the roasted bun tasty?
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tasty.
Lucia: 我来分发一下
Lucia: I'll distribute these.
Jake:驴肉对
Jake: Donkey meat, right?
Jake:这就是驴肉
Jake: This is donkey meat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我要个这个就行了
Tasha: I'll just take this one.
Tasha: 我不要筷子了
Tasha: I don't need chopsticks.
Lucia: 啊那那给给健康好了
Lucia: Ah, then give the chopsticks to Health.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那这筷子就放这
Lucia: Then I'll just put the chopsticks here.
Jake:我我还有
Jake: I have another set.
Jake:我还有一套餐具
Jake: I have another set of utensils.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是吗这是我的啊
Jake: Really? This is mine.
Tasha: 这这还有筷子呢
Tasha: There are more chopsticks here.
Lucia: 啊刚刚不是给你了一套
Lucia: Didn't I just give you a set?
Jake:这是啊这不是我
Jake: Yeah, this isn't mine.
Lucia: 笑死了我刚还以为你有两个
Lucia: I'm dying of laughter, I thought you had two sets.
Jake:我有两个人
Jake: I have two people.
Lucia: 人哈哈哈
Lucia: People, hahaha.
Shure: 卤煮火烧
Shure: Braised roasted bun.
Tasha: 你要吃这个是吗
Tasha: You want to eat this, right?
Jake:呃我也吃火烧
Jake: Uh, I'll also have a roasted bun.
Jake:今晚吃什么
Jake: What are we eating tonight?
Jake:麦麦当劳汉堡是吧
Jake: McDonald's burger, right?
Tasha: 呵呵哥
Tasha: Haha, bro.
Lucia: 你们这边有了吗
Lucia: Do you have it here?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes.
Jake:我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Jake: Have we eaten McDonald's burgers?
Jake:还肯德基
Jake: Or KFC?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:第一天肯德基是吧
Jake: First day was KFC, right?
Lucia: 那我吃了
Lucia: Then I ate it.
Shure: 要加点蒜泥吗
Shure: Want to add some garlic paste?
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Do you have it?
Tasha: 啥
Tasha: What?
其他人：你就你就翻译个标题
Others: Just translate the title.
Shure: 来是这里的
Shure: Here it is.
Shure: 帮忙拿一个蒜泥
Shure: Can you help grab some minced garlic?
Shure: 首先倒倒倒里了
Shure: First, pour it in.
Tasha: 啊我突然想要一个娃哈哈
Tasha: Oh, I suddenly want a Wahaha drink.
Jake:那你娃哈那
Jake: Then get a Wahaha.
Jake:那你待着吧
Jake: Just stay here.
Jake:你待着
Jake: Stay here.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Never mind.
Lucia: 我给你开了一瓶
Lucia: I opened a bottle for you.
Tasha: 还有谁要这个呀
Tasha: Who else wants this?
Lucia: 娃哈哈你还没喝呢
Lucia: You haven't even drunk your Wahaha.
Jake:是是是我想是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I think so.
Tasha: 嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Mhm, mhm.
Tasha: 拿个餐巾纸
Tasha: Get a napkin.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:  餐巾纸 那
Tasha: Napkin, here.
Tasha:  我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:娃哈哈
Jake: Wahaha.
Tasha: 你就掌握了一个芒果
Tasha: You're holding a mango.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:来点娃哈哈上去
Jake: Add a bit of Wahaha to it.
Tasha: 别的人 喝吗
Tasha: Does anyone else want to drink it?
Jake:还有几个呀
Jake: How many are left?
Jake:那都拿上去吧
Jake: Just bring them all up.
Tasha: 对都拿上去刚刚好
Tasha: Yeah, bring them all up, it's perfect.
Jake:北冰洋的吸管
Jake: A straw for the Arctic Ocean drink.
Jake:餐巾纸
Jake: Napkin.
Tasha: 拿了
Tasha: Got it.
其他人：我操你来了太帅了
Others: Wow, you came, you're so cool.
Shure: 我要要北冰洋
Shure: I want an Arctic Ocean drink.
Jake:这卤乳是不是得有勺啊
Jake: Shouldn't there be a spoon for the braised tofu?
Jake:不用了
Jake: Never mind.
Jake:啊有勺
Jake: Oh, there's a spoon.
Jake:哦原来有勺可以
Jake: Oh, so there's a spoon, that's fine.
Shure: 他火上好像都在底下
Shure: The fire seems to be all at the bottom.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McMcMcDonald's burger.
Jake:比炸弹好吃
Jake: Tastes better than a bomb.
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Braised pork.
Shure: 招信他的杨老板
Shure: Trust Jake on that.
Alice:有这些量
Alice: With this amount.
Shure: 他不专业
Shure: He's not professional.
Shure: 我怎么插
Shure: How do I insert it?
Shure: 插不进去啊
Shure: I can't insert it.
Tasha: 有有花然后
Tasha: There's a flower then...
Alice:嗯加加油
Alice: Keep it up.
Alice:应该还有个腐乳
Alice: There should be some fermented tofu.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake:你为什么不吃卤猪
Jake: Why don't you eat braised pork?
Tasha: 它长得 好丑呀
Tasha: It looks so ugly.
Jake:好丑
Jake: So ugly.
Lucia: 我吃到血味了
Lucia: I taste blood.
Jake:这丑吗
Jake: Is this ugly?
Tasha: 丑他都是大肠小肠大脑小脑的
Tasha: Ugly, it's all intestines, brains...
Shure: 感觉瞧不起谁呢
Shure: Feels like looking down on someone.
Shure: 谁也没有个东西哈哈哈
Shure: No one's got that thing, hahaha.
Tasha: 那你为什么把别人吃下肚
Tasha: So why did you eat someone else?
Jake:它有3种是吧大肠肝
Jake: There are three kinds, right? Large intestine, liver.
Jake:是肺肺
Jake: It's the lungs.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 火 烧是什么 是哪个部位
Tasha: What is "huoshao"? Which part is that?
Jake:面啊
Jake: It's flour.
Lucia: 我也想问
Lucia: I want to ask too.
Lucia: 火烧是哪个部位
Lucia: Which part is "huoshao"?
Shure: 对这面块块就是火烧
Shure: Yeah, this piece of dough is "huoshao".
Tasha: 啊是什么
Tasha: Ah, what is it?
Jake:面
Jake: Flour.
Jake:就驴肉火烧
Jake: It's just donkey meat "huoshao".
Jake:就是驴肉和火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat and "huoshao".
Jake:就是驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat "huoshao".
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Jake:煎驴肉就是那个东西
Jake: Fried donkey meat, that's the stuff.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right, look.
Shure: 面面面饼饼
Shure: Flour, flour, dough, dough.
Tasha: 这个就是火烧
Tasha: This is "huoshao".
Lucia: 啊
Jake:对用火烧出来的面
Jake: Yeah, the noodles made by burning with fire.
Lucia: 好神奇啊
Lucia: That's amazing.
Lucia: 发出感叹
Lucia: I'm impressed.
Jake:多半是没吃过牛肉火烧
Jake: You probably haven't had beef fire-baked buns.
Shure: 我有次吃河北人带来的卤火烧
Shure: I once had braised fire-baked buns brought by someone from Hebei.
Shure: 真的是真他妈好吃
Shure: It was really damn good.
Jake:怎么带过来的就
Jake: How did they bring it over?
Shure: 就他带过来
Shure: They just brought it over.
Shure: 就是冷的
Shure: It was cold.
Shure: 我去
Shure: Oh my.
Jake:这3个东西
Jake: These three things.
Jake:你们用了吗
Jake: Did you use them?
Shure: 用了把蒜汁和那个辣椒油浇了就行
Shure: Yeah, just pour the garlic sauce and chili oil, that's all.
Jake:用了
Jake: Used it.
Shure: 那个韭菜花一般不加
Shure: Usually we don't add chive flower sauce.
Shure: low口
Shure: Too basic.
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This one, this one.
Shure: 必须的
Shure: Definitely.
Jake:这啥啊
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 你说什么就是什么
Tasha: Whatever you say it is.
Jake:吃啥呀腐乳
Jake: What are we eating, fermented tofu?
Alice:腐乳
Alice: Fermented tofu.
Jake:腐乳加吗
Jake: Should we add fermented tofu?
Shure: 腐乳不加
Shure: No fermented tofu.
Jake:不加好
Jake: No, good.
Shure: 也可以尝试
Shure: You could try it though.
Shure: 但我没加过
Shure: But I've never added it.
Shure: 我不够local
Shure: I'm not that local.
Jake:咱要不顺势把豆汁打开尝尝
Lucia: 我们买豆汁了吗
Lucia: Did we buy soy milk?
Tasha: 买了一瓶
Tasha: We bought a bottle.
Tasha: 不是买了一瓶吗
Tasha: Didn't we buy a bottle?
Alice:不是买了一瓶吗
Alice: Didn't we buy a bottle?
Tasha: 哪 呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:先说要吃完吗
Jake: Finish eating first?
Jake:别的吃不了
Jake: Can't eat anything else.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 吃饱了再喝那个不是危险性更大吗
Lucia: Isn't it more dangerous to drink that when you're already full?
Lucia: 哈哈哈说这么直白干什么
Lucia: Hahaha, why say it so bluntly?
Tasha: 已经要吐了
Tasha: I feel like I'm gonna puke.
Shure: 我不吃
Shure: I'm not eating it.
Shure: 我喝过
Shure: I've drunk it before.
Lucia: 我没吃过
Lucia: I've never eaten it.
Shure: 我怕吃完咱们又泼一杯了
Shure: I'm afraid if I eat it, we'll just throw up again.
Tasha: 就是那次在街头买了一一袋
Tasha: That time we bought a bag on the street.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:街头一单
Jake: A street deal.
Tasha: 就是
Tasha: Exactly.
Shure: 这个活
Shure: This job.
Alice:我们同学3个人去
Alice: Three of us classmates went.
Shure: 必须我来干
Shure: I have to do it.
Tasha: 我们同学三个人去买了一罐
Tasha: We bought a can.
Tasha: 当时说是什么味来着
Tasha: What did it taste like again?
Tasha: 反正中午吃的全部都吐了
Tasha: Anyway, we threw up everything we ate at lunch.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 听起来好危险
Lucia: Sounds dangerous.
其他人：这个真的会在几十年后让我们踩
Others: This could really cause us trouble in a few decades.
Jake:这个怎么怎么炒啊
Jake: How do you even cook this?
Shure: 你相你相信30年后财务自由
Shure: Do you believe you'll be financially free in 30 years?
Shure: 不相信你能活到30年
Shure: I don't even believe I'll live for 30 years.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 我应该差不多吧
Shure: I think it's possible, though.
Shure: 50岁我还活不到吗
Shure: Won't I make it to 50?
Shure: 那差不多
Shure: That's close enough.
Lucia: 而且还要考虑通货膨胀因素
Lucia: And you have to consider inflation too.
Shure: 金币很珍惜
Shure: Gold coins are precious.
Shure: 就是只有150个
Shure: There are only 150 of them.
Shure: 到时候要是马斯克看上了马斯克
Shure: What if Musk takes a liking to it and...
Shure: 再配上发一句话
Shure: Posts something about it?
Tasha: 呵哥
Tasha: Oh, bro.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 那就得
Lucia: Then...
Lucia: 这个监制的任务就得交给杨老板了
Lucia: We'll have to give the production task to Jake.
小薇 ：真的会发生150个币吗
Tasha: Will we really get 150 coins?
Shure: 我跟你说
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 有一天就是大一的时候
Shure: One day, when we were freshmen...
Jake:是发150个币
Jake: Did they issue 150 coins?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 大一的时候张晨他晚上睡得很晚
Shure: Back in our freshman year, Zhang Chen would stay up really late.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 然后张晨在刷推特
Shure: And Zhang Chen would be scrolling through Twitter.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 看见了马斯克说屎逼
Shure: He saw Elon Musk saying something really rude.
Shure: 你知道那个币
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 骂的张晨当时就刷到了
Shure: Zhang Chen saw the tweet right then.
Shure: 其实其实我没睡
Shure: Actually, I wasn't asleep.
Jake:就买了
Jake: And he bought it.
Shure: 但是他以为我睡
Shure: But he thought I was.
Shure: 他没跟我说那个时候在
Shure: He didn't tell me about it back then.
Shure: 那个时候在地下都没那
Shure: At that time, it wasn't on the major exchanges.
Shure: 那个史币都没上大交易所
Shure: 马上他直接下了个小小交易所
Shure: He quickly bought $2,000 worth.
Shure: 赶快买了2,000的
Shure: And it turned into $8,000.
Shure: 史币交钱就变8,000
Shure: 之前还跟当时一直在宿舍挖一胎房
Shure: Before that, he used to mine crypto in our dorm room.
Shure: 嗯刮了个小一片
Shure: He scratched up a small area.
Shure: 把我鞋卡往滑梯了
Shure: And my shoe got caught on the slide.
Jake: ：哦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 我去维修的时候
Shure: When I went to repair it,
Shure: 然后问你这鞋上有两道黑伤
Shure: They asked why there were two black marks on my shoe.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:什么卡挖的
Jake: What caused the marks?
Jake:就就我给你了哈哈
Jake: I gave it to you, haha.
Shure: 不不不
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 然后那个训练老人就很不可思议地说
Shure: The repair guy was really surprised and said,
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Shure: 说我就是玩游戏打英雄联盟打多了
Shure: He said I must have played too much League of Legends.
其他人：打英雄联盟打多了
Everyone: Played too much League of Legends.
Shure: 其实每天24小时挖矿挖的
Shure: But I was actually mining 24/7.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那你们宿舍电不会耗很快吗
Lucia: Didn't your dorm electricity run out quickly?
Shure: 那两边就是我跟张二婶的铺电
Shure: Yeah, we were maxing out the circuits on both sides.
Shure: 因为这段时间呢
Shure: Because during that time,
Shure: 那段时间地太值钱了
Shure: Crypto was worth a lot.
Shure: 电费已经完全耗完了
Shure: We completely used up all the electricity.
Shure: 就大概是三三月份发的吧
Shure: It was probably issued around March.
Shure: 五月份国家就出台这个政策
Shure: The country released this policy in May.
Shure: 然后就医药展
Shure: Then there was the medical expo.
Jake:路人
Jake: Passerby.
Shure: 对不起地不起
Shure: Sorry, really sorry.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 我知道虚拟货币极其不稳定，国家 就应该支持
Shure: I know virtual currency is extremely unstable, the country should support it.
小薇 ：哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 都是泡沫经济
Shure: It's all a bubble economy.
Tasha: 嗨
Tasha: Hi.
Jake:标签打成危险
Jake: Label it as dangerous.
Jake:就是网管
Jake: It's the internet manager.
Jake:基本上就干这个
Jake: Basically doing this job.
Jake:就是计个时间
Jake: Just keeping time.
Shure: 哈哈哈要
Shure: Hahaha, need to report.
Jake:哈哈哈要举报
Shure: 不知道你们记不记得那个天津那个人
Shure: Do you remember that guy from Tianjin?
Shure: 也没酒驾
Shure: No drunk driving.
Shure: 就   撞人那种事
Shure: Just hit someone like that.
Shure: 架桥上撞人
Shure: Hit someone on the bridge.
Shure: 感觉全是炒币炒多了
Lucia: 还挺好吃的嗯
Lucia: It's pretty tasty, yeah.
Shure: 不是你第一次吃啊
Shure: It's not your first time eating this.
Lucia: 对没吃过
Lucia: Yeah, never had it before.
Shure: 你以前吃肥肠吗
Shure: Did you eat chitterlings before?
Lucia: 肥肠我吃过
Lucia: I’ve had chitterlings before.
Lucia: 放在面里当浇头的那种
Lucia: As a topping in noodles.
Tasha: 那你可能会吃炒肝
Tasha: Then you might like stir-fried liver.
Alice:那你可能也会吃炒肝
Alice: Then you might also like stir-fried liver.
Lucia: 说北京的那种炒肝吗
Lucia: You mean Beijing-style stir-fried liver?
Lucia: 啊我不喜欢那个
Lucia: Oh, I don’t like that.
Lucia: 特别咸我觉得
Lucia: It’s too salty for me.
Jake:去吧。
Jake: Go ahead.
Lucia: 嗯很咸嗯
Lucia: Yeah, very salty.
Shure: 我觉得炒肝没入味
Shure: I think stir-fried liver lacks flavor.
Lucia: 是不是我去的地方不对呀
Lucia: Maybe I went to the wrong place.
Lucia: 我觉得特别咸
Lucia: I think it's really salty.
Alice:可能是炒干
Alice: Maybe it's overcooked.
Alice:还没这个咸呢
Alice: Not as salty as this though.
Alice:就比这个会淡一点点
Alice: It should be a bit less salty than this.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 下次再试试
Lucia: Let's try it again next time.
Alice:感觉超哥糊嘴
Alice: Feels like it's sticking to my mouth.
Lucia: 对它是一种黏糊糊的
Lucia: Yeah, it's kind of sticky.
Lucia: 是吧像放了布丁粉一样的感觉
Lucia: Right? Feels like there's pudding powder in it.
Alice:感觉是藕粉的那种清晰
Alice: Feels like the clarity of lotus root starch.
Lucia: 嗯对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Alice:黏糊吧唧
Alice: Sticky and gooey.
Jake:是什么呀辣椒
Jake: What is it, chili?
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil.
Jake:哎我去
Jake: Oh, come on.
Alice:韭花酱
Alice: Fermented leek sauce.
Alice:咸
Alice: Salty.
Jake:那我多蘸多加点汤是吧
Jake: Then I'll dip more and add more soup, right?
Alice:你直接倒吧
Alice: Just pour it directly.
其他人：十八八
Others: Eighteen eight.
Tasha: 挺咸
Tasha: Pretty salty.
Jake:哎哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey, hey.
Tasha: 没事儿，哎哎哎
Tasha: It's okay, hey, hey, hey.
Tasha: 米米多米诺骨牌
Tasha: Mi Mi Domino.
Jake:你这吸管咬得可以
Jake: You really chewed that straw well.
Jake:他这吸管
Jake: Look at his straw.
Tasha: 我就想看看有没有跟我一样
Tasha: I just wanted to see if anyone else is like me.
Jake:好像没有
Jake: Seems like no one.
Lucia: 我一般都是喝完了才有
Lucia: I usually do that after I finish drinking.
Jake:咬的很有艺术感
Jake: It's chewed artistically.
Tasha: 这是一种领地意识
Tasha: It's a kind of territorial instinct.
Tasha: 倒是没有第二个人想偷我的饮料
Tasha: No one else wants to steal my drink.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Alice:你会喝羊杂汤吗
Alice: Do you drink lamb offal soup?
Lucia: 我喝过
Lucia: I've had it before.
Alice:喜欢吗
Alice: Do you like it?
Lucia: 取决于他做的好不好
Lucia: Depends on how well it's made.
Jake:喝什么哦
Jake: What are you drinking?
Lucia: 羊杂汤我感觉有的做的还确实还行
Lucia: Lamb offal soup, I feel like sometimes it's actually quite good.
Alice:羊杂汤
Alice: Lamb offal soup.
Lucia: 有的做的不好吃有点腥
Lucia: Sometimes it's not cooked well and tastes a bit gamey.
Jake:泡馍用的吗
Jake: Is it for the bread soup?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 其实像这里面这个肺我就不是特喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I don't really like the lung in it.
Lucia: 因为我刚吃了一块饭
Lucia: Because I just had a piece.
Lucia: 他有雪块味
Lucia: It tasted kind of bloody.
Lucia: 我就没再吃了
Lucia: So I stopped eating it.
Lucia: 但是其他的都很好吃
Lucia: But everything else is delicious.
Alice:腥好吃啊
Alice: The gamey taste is nice.
Lucia: 对心好吃
Lucia: Yeah, it's tasty.
Lucia: 腥没有味道
Lucia: The gamey part has no flavor.
Alice:而且比较韧
Alice: And it's quite tough.
Lucia: 而且很有嚼劲
Lucia: And very chewy.
Jake:咱这豆汁什么时候喝呀
Jake: When are we drinking this mung bean milk?
Jake:明天后天谁买的
Jake: Who bought it for tomorrow or the day after?
Shure: 我不喝
Shure: I'm not drinking it.
Jake:哈哈哈这是你吗
Jake: Haha, was it you?
Shure: 谁买谁喝
Shure: Whoever buys it, drinks it.
Tasha: 谁买谁
Tasha: Whoever buys it...
Alice:谁买谁可以指定喝
Alice: Whoever buys it can choose who drinks it.
Jake:谁花钱谁喝酒
Jake: Whoever spends the money drinks it.
Lucia: 谁指定喝可爱酒
Lucia: Whoever chooses drinks the cute drink.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: That's fine.
Jake:你开了吗
Jake: Did you open it?
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 超市里这种豆汁
Lucia: The mung bean milk in the supermarket...
Lucia: 会不会做一些口味上的改良啊
Lucia: Would they modify the taste a bit?
Lucia: 要不然话不就没人买吗
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would buy it.
Tasha: 对啊，肯定是这样子的
Tasha: Yeah, definitely.
Lucia: 哇肚子疼
Lucia: Wow, my stomach hurts.
Tasha: hello
Tasha: Hello.
Alice:thank you
Alice: Thank you.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 你知道怎么把握另一台电脑
Shure: Do you know how to manage the other computer?
Lucia: 这个要用的死面
Lucia: You need stiff dough for this.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What is it?
Alice:火烧
Alice: Baked cake.
Tasha: 应该是吧，死面就会比较硬
Tasha: Yeah, stiff dough makes it harder.
Alice:嗯不宣
Alice: Hmm, not fluffy.
Tasha: 我发现北方的馒头都不宣，就是特 硬的那种
Tasha: I found that the steamed buns in the north aren't fluffy, they're really hard.
Alice:我们家做馒头老用死面
Alice: My family always makes steamed buns with dead dough.
Alice:我就不爱吃馒头
Alice: I just don't like steamed buns.
Tasha: 那我爱吃活面馒头
Tasha: Well, I love steamed buns made with live dough.
Alice:其实也不是死的
Alice: Actually, it's not dead.
Alice:有发酵但是比较邦邦硬比较湿
Alice: It ferments but it's still quite hard and moist.
Jake:哎这怎么开
Jake: Hey, how do you open this?
Jake:这是要干啥
Jake: What's this for?
Shure: 不是我开的
Shure: I didn't open it.
Jake:遥控器在哪火
Jake: Where's the remote?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 是不是很好玩
Lucia: Isn't it fun?
Lucia: 还有这个这个
Lucia: And this, this too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: AI 你学会了吗
Lucia: AI, did you learn it?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哎这个像鸽子
Jake: Hey, this looks like a pigeon.
Katrina: 哎快断气了
Katrina: Hey, it's about to suffocate.
Lucia: 这个是大雁吗
Lucia: Is this a wild goose?
Tasha: 好这
Tasha: Okay, this.
Jake:这是两只手
Jake: These are two hands.
Jake:哈哈哈这啥呀这是你
Jake: Hahaha, what's this? Is this you?
Alice:哈哈哈你好AI啊
Alice: Hahaha, you are so AI!
Jake:好恩爱啊哈哈哈
Jake: So affectionate, hahaha.
Alice:蛇怎么弄啊
Alice: How do you do a snake?
Lucia: 不会哎有点像你说那种会吐吐吐
Lucia: I can't, it kinda looks like the one that spits, spits, spits...
Lucia: 那个什么呢
Lucia: What's that called?
Jake:鸵鸟
Jake: Ostrich.
Jake:孔雀
Jake: Peacock.
Lucia: 嘿嘿
Lucia: Hehe.
Tasha: 这像不像鹿
Tasha: Does this look like a deer?
Tasha: 哎像的像的
Tasha: Hey, it does, it does.
Lucia: 哎像的像的
Lucia: Hey, it does, it does.
Jake:鸡冠头
Jake: Rooster comb head.
Lucia: 为什么咱俩同一个手势
Lucia: Why are we making the same gesture?
Lucia: 你就是鹿而我是孔雀哈哈哈
Lucia: You are the deer and I am the peacock, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我记得我以前还会弄
Lucia: I remember I used to do this before.
Alice:嘿眼珠会动
Alice: Hey, the eyes move!
Lucia: 哎好看
Lucia: Oh, looks nice.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:这是石头
Jake: This is a rock.
Lucia: 这猫
Lucia: This cat.
Tasha: 噢
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 石头
Tasha: A rock.
Alice:正在思考人类为什么要
Alice: Thinking about why humans...
Jake:一个山
Jake: A mountain.
Jake:山洞
Jake: A cave.
Jake:最左边
Jake: The far left.
Lucia: 不会了小时候会好多
Lucia: I used to know a lot when I was a kid.
Lucia: 我现在就只记得这个和这个狗汪汪
Lucia: Now I only remember this and the dog barking.
Alice: ：会咬人吗
Alice: Does it bite?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: ：enough
Alice: Enough.
Lucia: 给大家表演一个天狗吃月亮月亮呢
Lucia: Let me show you a celestial dog eating the moon. Where's the moon?
Jake:哈哈这个
Jake: Haha, this one.
Alice:这是鸭子吗
Alice: Is this a duck?
Lucia: 好像好像驴
Lucia: Looks like, looks like a donkey.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这是什么 哈哈哈
Tasha: What is this? Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:螃蟹这是
Jake: It's a crab.
Jake:这是螃蟹这是螃蟹
Jake: This is a crab, this is a crab.
Lucia: 有点像再多两条腿就
Lucia: Looks like, if it had two more legs...
Tasha: 这是龙吗
Tasha: Is this a dragon?
Jake:给你加俩
Jake: I'll add two for you.
Jake:这是狗
Jake: It's a dog.
Tasha: 狗
Tasha: A dog.
Alice: ：这是东邪西毒的狗吗
Alice: Is this the dog from "The East is Red"?
Tasha: 这 啊蝴蝶
Tasha: This... oh, a butterfly.
Lucia: 啊原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 这是不是要那个傻吊
Lucia: Do we need that thing...
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 国际友好手势
Lucia: International friendly gesture
Lucia: 这是兔子
Lucia: This is a rabbit
Alice:这是美羊羊
Alice: This is Pleasant Goat
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Shure: 嘉羊羊美羊羊
Shure: Jia Yangyang, Pleasant Goat
Shure: 美羊羊这是美羊羊
Shure: Pleasant Goat, this is Pleasant Goat
Lucia: 我真是没有
Lucia: I really don't have it
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈可还行
Lucia: Haha, but it's okay
Lucia: 好饱哦
Lucia: I'm so full
Jake:连你的怎么也没有
Jake: Even yours isn't working
Jake:看看你的是不是
Jake: Check if yours is...
Jake:看一看你是不是没有开
Jake: See if you didn't turn it on
Jake:还是你每次要摁一下
Jake: Or you need to press it every time
Jake:它得亮着它才
Jake: It needs to be on for it to...
Jake:你看一看
Jake: Take a look
Lucia: 您这个条他都没变化的
Lucia: This strip hasn't changed at all
Jake:那就电多
Jake: That means there's a lot of power
Jake:可以看一下手机是不是在前进
Jake: You can check if your phone is moving forward
Jake:啊不是
Jake: Oh, no
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Oh, OK
Jake:就是手机上
Jake: It's on the phone
Lucia: IC就是手机上看这个电视电
Lucia: I see, you check the power on the phone
Jake:对对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right
Jake:他电怎么样还
Jake: How's the power?